good morning everyone I think uh the
time being just after 10 we will get
started
representative Sanborn is unable to be
here today so I will share today's uh
committee
and um I want to welcome up
dra
good morning Mr chair members of the
I believe we left off on page 37 of our
presentation we were just about to start
the interest in dividends tax
which Keane is going to cover Chris does
have extra copies if anyone needs them
and before we get started on the
interest in dividends does anybody have
any questions on the other taxes that we
have covered previously
and obviously if you do you know we can
we can get back to that too at the end
but um if anyone had anything pressing
right now we could
address that
all right seeing none I think we'll
continue with interest and dividends
good morning uh Kimi Wong Department of
Revenue
so right now we are on page 37 of the
slide
and we're starting off with interest in
interest in dividends tax is currently
um for taxable periods ending on or
after December 31 2023 is at four
percent tax rate uh prior to that it's
at a five percent uh tax rate and this
tax rate is uh decreasing year over year
and will be repeal effective uh Jan 1 of
2027. all New Hampshire residents
fiduciaries llc's Partnerships and
associations with income from interest
and dividends will be subject to this
tax
currently the threshold for uh the
filing as well as income exemption is uh
2 400 annually and 4 800 for joint
followers and that's an additional
exemption for a residence age 65 and
older for twelve hundred dollars as well
as well as for our buying and disabled
similarly 1200 exemptions
the return is filed on April 15th it was
due on April 15th and uh similar with
the business taxes as an extension to
file the return if the taxpayer is not
able to file that return on time however
that's just to file a return it's not to
pay the taxes
and uh similar with the BPT there's also
the um requirement to pay estimated
taxes and this will these estimated
taxes uh due on April 15th June 15
September 15 and January 15th
um of the Year itself
um if they estimated liabilities in
moving on to page 38
this is the uh the so data that shows
the split uh the the breakdown of the uh
the filers so on the left hand side you
will have the pie chart to show the
large amount of filers uh individuals at
97.5 percent and uh 2.5 percent of them
uh of the filers are Partnerships in the
states however when you look at the
interest in dividends tax breakdown you
see that um the 39 that from this filing
what exactly is the portion that income
portion that makes up these uh taxable
IND
ual see here the large amount of that
will be a 39 is from dividends and then
42 percent is from distribution
um you've heard the distinguishing
um language between okay what's the
dividend and what's a distribution
essentially this dividends would be uh
the dividends that you receive normally
when you receive a 1099 div and you
report that on your federal return on
your 1040
Top Line there are dividend income and
then distribution would be uh
distribution would be any kind of
distribution of cash or property that's
distributed from an escrow trust in the
states Partnerships and LLCs those are
distributions and those are treated as
moving on to slide 39
this graph shows the uh the 10 years of
the interest and dividend components for
the for a 10-year Trend so this is a
interesting dividend component not the
the tax itself so this is what is
the the components that makes up the the
IND income once again you'll see the
texture 21 you'll see the
large portion of it is from
distributions and dividends and the
small portion is from interest income
and then looking down at the the chart
at the bottom and you'll see actually
provide you with the uh the numbers in
billions and that will correlate with
moving on to like 40 it is the IND tax
revenue for a 10-year Trend and you see
that the um
the IND income is trending upwards and
then in fiskier 21 there's a slight
downward Trend and then fiscal year 282
it's going up uh as well and likely the
influencing factors on this white fiscal
year 22 is moving so just drastically up
is likely because of as you see from the
previous Slide the last portion of the
IND is from distributions and dividends
so likely the the payout from dividend
and distributions has increased for
fiscal 20 to as well as also the
representative doors
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question is any of this uh
increased do you think related to covid
or is it just people are taking
advantage of they're just you know their
so in terms of the uh in terms of the
the 10-year Revenue Trend yes and where
it's spiking here at the end a little
bit in 22.
um in terms of covet I I the covet
impact were likely that would impact the
IND Revenue would likely be from the
Federal
money coming in to to businesses and if
the businesses are doing well and they
distribute and and provide higher
distributions and dividends to to their
shareholders or members uh that you ever
would you'll see that direct correlation
into in terms of the increase in the uh
in the IND Revenue okay um I think that
would be the the direct
um or indirect yeah correlation okay
[Music]
would we had the tax cuts and jobs act
and on
As I understood it a large part of the
prophets from
on
that that went to large corporations
ended up coming coming back as profits
to us so so we've had this artificial
stimulus and that one I understand a
fair amount of that act is is ending
soon
could you yes tell us about that
yes representative so that bit on the uh
the tcja
um that that we've
that we uh sorry so the tcga re changed
the tax structure and required a uh a
deemed distribution uh from foreign
dividends coming back into New Hampshire
uh sorry into the US so essentially that
impacts the BPT more
um and we're treating that as uh when on
the federal side when there's a
requirement to report it as a deemed
distribution
and um so there is no sort of incentive
for the companies to keep the money
offshore and it therefore actually make
an actual distribution back to the U.S
holders
so New Hampshire taxes the uh dividends
foreign dividends when they actually
received by by the U.S holders and so
when they actually do that we do the
actual distribution that's when we
follow up follow up to that one on but
also they although there were quite a
few businesses that weren't paying what
they were supposed to be paying uh there
was on a
on a cut in the the amount of tax that
the corporations had to pay at the same
time
and I think I remember that that that
was only in order to meet budget
criteria it was only authorized for a
certain number of years and that that's
ending
or some part of it is ending
there are Provisions within tcga that
kind of phase out or change over time so
that might be what you're referring to
that some of the the changes will phase
out or change as years go on to answer
your first question though I think it's
similar to the question about covid so
to the extent that that money was
repatriated back to the United States
and then those corporations decided to
make distributions or dividends with
some of those profits that came back
then we would see that impact in IND as
well so although to Keane's point the
foreign dividend paid back to the U.S
entity would be a taxable event for BPT
purposes if that profit then further
shifted to
shareholders or members based on
dividends or distributions we would see
that here so it's kind of a two-step
thank you and then follow up can I this
isn't a follow-up so if someone else has
a question
right okay we'll go to representative
uluri and then we'll go around again
thank you representative thank you just
chair so if I understand what you're
saying
because the
job jobs and taxi whatever the hell it's
called
which is supposed to Sunset I think in
26.
um
because that required a repatriation of
offshore account monies back to the
United States the profits of the United
States businesses including those
businesses located in New Hampshire
increased because the profits increased
the distribution of interest and
dividends or dividends in this case from
The Profit that the company saw
increased and because the distribution
so was the state because we tax it
where do we stand I think is what
representative almond is trying to get
at considering that we're also most
likely facing a recession
within a couple of quarters
so to answer that question
I don't believe it's a hundred percent
correct to say that the tax cut and jobs
act will sunset in 26. there are
Provisions that are changing
the
deemed repatriation was almost like a
one-time event where the profits for
many years that had been held offshore
by U.S corporations were deemed to be
returned to the U.S and so businesses
were able then to actually repatriate
those profits
and not be taxed a second time because
it was taxed under the deemed
repatriation so we kind of saw a
one-time impact of that
um profits that had been held in foreign
entities returned to the U.S the
treatment will remain the same going
forward so we kind of saw a blip as many
years of profit were deemed to be
repatriated but the treatment of those
repatriations is going to remain the
same going forward so it was a one-time
event but it also the treatment is going
to remain the same so the to the extent
that businesses continue to repatriate
those foreign profits and pay out those
profits via distributions or dividends
follow-up
thank you Mr chair okay
what does that mean as far as Revenue
estimates four years out
so I think we saw the largest kind of
one-time impact when that initial deemed
repatriation and actual repatriation
occurred right now I don't anticipate
but Keane's about to correct me if I'm
wrong I don't anticipate significant
differences in year over year interest
in dividends Revenue as a result of that
that we would need to account for
we're kind of in a new normal we've seen
the impact and I don't think that
there's any changes that we need to
account for
in the period that you're going to be
and I also just want to add that uh
deemed repatriation from the tcga that
essentially is the mechanism for the
federal government to change the
taxation for corporations from a
worldwide taxation basis to a more of a
territorial basis and to assist in that
change is required to I can't remember
the specifics on the policy is that
they've changed and therefore requiring
the uh the treatment of these offshore
funds and having them deemed repatriated
back to the U.S and so that when that
occurred is to facilitate the transition
from the worldwide to the territorial
system
um and if and that's that one-time event
and we still continue tax on a actual
distribution so
um whenever if the the whenever the
company's offshore companies find that
okay they have uh
uh funds offshore that they want to
actually distribute back to the US that
would be when we see
um that
our BPD going up and if
following that thought if the company
would follow continue on to distribute
that um that funds to the shareholders
all right
I'll I'll take that okay
so the IND is going away but the
money is still going to be there which
is going to show up on the BPT side
that's correct that all right so it's
it's not really going away
so I think the the concept of it going
away
as Keen just kind of mentioned this
deemed repatriation that happened at the
beginning of the tax cut and jobs act
for federal purposes generated
um significant amount of taxable profits
federally right because the amounts were
deemed to be repatriated it was many
years of profits that had been held
offshore so the federal government was
going to tax a large portion of profits
that hadn't been taxable previously that
was going to generate a fair amount of
one-time taxable
income for businesses so to help balance
that out there were a number of cuts to
the federal tax code that occurred at
the same time so that businesses did not
see this significant spike in their
taxable liability right so
the repatriation was going to increase
your taxable liability but there were
other Provisions that were going to
change or be cut to decrease the taxable
liability hoping to end up
somewhere in the middle and now what's
happening is some of those cuts or
decreases in businesses taxable
liability are starting to phase out as
this deemed repatriation has phased in
so there was the one-time bump of many
years of foreign profits that were
taxable now we're just taxing foreign
profits on more of an ongoing basis and
so we've as Keane mentioned transitioned
to this territorial system where we're
kind of trying to get to that middle
point so when we talk about certain
things in the tax cut and jobs act
coming to an end it's that phasing out
as we start to reach this new normal
going forward
hopefully that makes sense well flat tax
I think the uh
important question for us as we try to
do our Revenue estimates and look to the
future is that what's happening as we
come off of that
first bump
and go forward and whether it's going
forward
above where it would have been
or not given the very you know other
there are lots of elements in this and
what I'm wondering is whether any of the
National groups study including the
government have been tracking
they um this issue is is pretty
fundamental and in terms of what are the
profits that are taxable that go into
our calculation of of profits
so the thing to remember for New
Hampshire purposes with the tax cut and
jobs act tcja and this deemed
repatriation is New Hampshire is a
static Conformity state so we conform to
a specific date of the Internal Revenue
code
not all states operate that way some
states are what's called rolling
Conformity where the state just adopts
the changes to the federal code as they
happen
New Hampshire and many other states are
static Conformity so we did not conform
to the tax cut and jobs act until after
the deemed repatriation had occurred for
federal purposes
so what we see now in New Hampshire in
terms of repatriation
benefit Revenue impact is when those
distributions are actually or Dividends
are actually paid back from the foreign
entity to the United States and those
are taxable for New Hampshire purposes
because at the federal level they have
been deemed to be repatriated
there is an incentive for businesses to
actually pay that money back because
they've already paid tax on it federally
so when they pay it back in the form of
a dividend at the federal government
they've already paid tax on it so that
actual payment is tax-free because it
was previously taxed but for New
Hampshire purposes we collect the tax
so I think the short answer is there is
a federal incentive to pay that dividend
back that didn't exist before the tax
cut and jobs act and there is a that is
a taxable event for New Hampshire
purposes so it is likely that tcja
um increase the number of dividends that
were paid back from foreign entities to
the U.S therefore increased some portion
of our BPT base because of it and that
will remain that way going forward until
that provision is removed federally or
we and we update to a newer version of
the code
foreign
so I think at this point given when we
that tcja
that we've been conformed to tcj for a
number of years
I would say that that benefit or that
increased Revenue that we see because of
the
fact that these distributions are deemed
to be taxable federally and the tax has
already been paid that is in our Base
today
so when you're looking to and we'll talk
about this in a few slides when we start
the revenue estimating later this week
we're going to look at a base for 23 and
then a growth rate for 24 and 25. I
would say that that that benefit from
tcga is in the base of 23. and there is
at this point no reason that I think we
need to make any specific adjustments to
representative plett
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question you referred that we're
periodic Conformity static Conformity so
we're conforming to 2018 other states
are continuously moving it up to stay
with the feds do you have uh positives
or negatives of making that move if we
were to develop a instant conformity
so with the rolling Conformity
um you don't have the opportunity to
review the changes that the federal
government has made and how that will
impact your state
so the static Conformity that we have we
the dra report to this committee and
Senate Ways and Means in March of every
year about the changes
from the code that we're currently tied
to to the current code and we kind of
inform you about what changes positive
or negative may exist and so you're able
to make an informed decision states that
do rolling Conformity again you're kind
of at the mercy of the federal
government and if they decide to make a
change that could be you know
potentially detrimental to revenues here
in New Hampshire you don't have the
opportunity to review that change you
I will say states that are rolling
Conformity
um typically have a broader tax base
than New Hampshire does so there's a
sales tax and an income tax as well so
there they could maybe take different
their risk profile might be different
representative roachford and then Mr
chair thank you for
my question and I just want to make sure
I'm understanding this correctly so I
think sometimes we look at
our BPT revenues
and equate that to
the temperature the the the health of
our businesses in the state of New
Hampshire but if I'm hearing you right
the BPT boost that we're seeing may be
secondary to some changes that the
federal government has made so it's
maybe not an accurate indicator of our
business climate in New Hampshire
correct and so when we went through the
BPT slides at the last presentation you
may remember that the majority of our
business profits tax revenue comes from
very large multinational corporations
and so it is probably a more indicative
barometer of their health
and our smaller you know New Hampshire
only businesses pay a very small portion
of our business profits tax so
the tax as a whole can kind of indicate
General Health of the economy but I
would caution about making any specific
assumptions about new hampshire-based
businesses from the business profits tax
revenue because it is primarily coming
from large multinational corporations
can I follow up
follow-up yeah so thank you
um So you you're saying it's a health of
the company but it may just be
indicative not necessarily the health of
the company but the change in tax
structure in the way we're seeing some
of those profits where we may not have
been seeing them fully prior to 2017
accounting for them but now now we are
correct okay correct thank you
I'd like to ask a question then we'll
get to representative ulery um so when
did most of the repatriation occur what
year
so for federal purposes that would have
occurred in 2017 the year 2017 and 2018
the year that the tax cut in jobs act
went into effect and then for New
Hampshire purposes we've seen that in
18 and 9 18 and forward
but again for New Hampshire purposes
it's only when the dividend is actually
paid actually paid back
so most I mean is it fair to say that
that effect is probably dropping off at
this point that was kind of my point
maybe not dropping off but it's just
kind of in our base at this point
there's no one-time revenue or
significant change that we really need
to account for the impact of tcja just
kind of exists in our base Revenue today
if that makes sense yes okay okay thank
you representative ulery and then rep
represented all me
thank you just to follow up on
representing Platt's uh uh question
regarding uh the rolling versus static
uh with the rolling is it fair to say
that under the adoption of a rolling
adoption of federal law we have uh sub
uh suborned New Hampshire's coordinate
yes New Hampshire's tax code becomes so
subordinate too
um subordinates entirely differently I'm
sorry about that
uh
federal law
replaces right right we surrendered our
sovereignty regarding setting tax law
right with rolling Conformity you are
just going to conform to what the
federal government has decided
um for the tax code for that year and so
having static Conformity you may you are
allowed to you have the opportunity to
make decisions and conform to specific
versions of the code decouple from
specific versions of the code if you so
choose
representative Olney
thank you um
I just wanted to point out that
yes the
have been getting more money and that
will continue but we may not see it
because from now on we're based on the
sales within New Hampshire
and we have no idea what that's going to
do to us yet
correct so how that is representative
always referring to the change in how we
apportion or how we split out the pie of
a um
of a business that operates in multiple
States and so we typically we
historically have looked at the payroll
the sales and the property of a business
to determine how much how large the
piece of the pie is in New Hampshire and
going forward we'll only be looking at
the sales of that business compared to
their sales everywhere else to determine
could I just have a follow-up follow-up
do it well this is actually going back
to BPT but on
it there must be some data on imports
and exports from the state
is there
so
we will have
a better idea of the impact of moving to
single sales Factor once we've started
started to receive and
have or have a significant number or a
representative number of returns with
market-based sourcing
because then we will have the new
sourcing method for services and
intangibles and we can extrapolate from
that what it would look like with just
sales so so we are close
um but we don't necessarily have it just
yet
um
and
if looking at import or export data we
would need to look at obviously both
goods and services
um
and we'd need to know the first Services
how
the apportionment Works under
market-based sourcing so
it's it's coming together
um but we don't have all the data just
yet
are we going to have that before the
budget is finished
no I didn't think so
thank you
representative Ellery
thank you Mr chair um you mentioned
Services I uh following a couple of
journals a couple of
beige not quite quite shoe law firms in
uh Manchester now have offices in London
and Paris and I think one of them has
one in Berlin too but uh I'm not sure
that's the service they're offering
so under cost of performance
we would look to where those Services
were provided so if the lawyer was
sitting here in New Hampshire and doing
that work then that work would be a
portion to New Hampshire
now we're looking at market-based
sourcing so we look at where the
customer is
so difference being if you had an office
in to use your example London in New
Hampshire
under cost of performance we would only
be
essentially taxing the services that
were performed here in New Hampshire
under market-based sourcing we're going
to tax all of the services that are
performed for New Hampshire customers
so if the New Hampshire if I'm the New
Hampshire customer and the attorney in
London and the attorney in New Hampshire
do work for me
then that is now going to get a portion
to New Hampshire so rather whether
service is performed it's where the
service is essentially received where
the customer is
follow up
not to use yes I will use initials for a
company who happens to operate in the
United Kingdom and in New Hampshire
How's that gonna if I don't know how you
separate that out how it's going to work
I I really don't not understand that uh
it's the responsibility of the business
essentially this the tax the services
the value of the services performed for
that those customers in New Hampshire
um will be the services that will be
okay looks like we are ready to okay
okay moving on to slide 41 the CSC
communication Services tax and right now
it so the CST is a seven percent tax on
two-way communication Services only and
uh this tax is paid by the customer so
it's essentially is a tax on the
customer but it's collected uh by the
service providers all two-way
communication Services providers are
responsible for collecting and limiting
the tax from the consumer to and filing
the return
the return is filed on a monthly basis
and is filed on the 15th day of the
following month
um and the uh if a liability under 100
per month returns a file quarterly and
are due by the 15th day of the month
following the quarter and once again
there's estimates to be paid estimates
are required if the tax liability is
over 10 000 a month
um and then it's paid collected it's
collected by the 15th day of the month
on slide 42 uh here you'll see the CST
revenue for a 10-year Trend
um it is has been steadily declining
since uh fiscal year 14 and then in
fiscal year 21 you do see a a sharper
decline to fiscal year 22 and the
potential reasons that we're seeing for
this sharp decline is because of how
companies service providers are
allocating the the two-way
Communications the services for that to
uh Voice versus for data as um for CST
Revenue the
services for data is not subject to for
internet data it's not subject to to the
so the Medicaid enhancement tax you'll
see is a little bit unique it's
essentially collected by dra but it is
spent by DHHS
so Medicaid enhancement tax is a 5.4
percent tax on net Patient Service
revenue of hospitals taxes paid by
General hospitals that provide inpatient
and outpatient services but not
including government facilities
the tax period for met is a 12-month
period that begins on July 1 and ends on
June 30 so it follows the state fiscal
year
but the taxes due is based on the
hospital's fiscal year that ends Within
that taxable period
so it is
uh not as straightforward as a regular
business tax return where you just
operate under a normal for most
businesses calendar year
the hospitals must file a non-binding
estimate on or before January 15th of
their estimated tax payment and then
they're required to make the payment and
file their return no later than April
15th in the same year
for this year for the taxable period
that's
um
is going to end June 30th 2023 the
non-binding estimates for the Medicaid
enhancement tax were
302.1 million and that is up from the
prior taxable period actual amounts paid
uh we have a couple questions uh
representative ulery
yes thank you
um
we're talking about Medicaid therefore
we're talking about federal dollars
being sent back to the state which the
state is essentially skimming off uh I'm
using that phrase deliberately uh some
of the monies that would be otherwise be
going directly into patient services to
give it to other patient services
someplace else
foreign
who oversees where that other money is
going I mean you collect it but does
anyone oversee it or is that strictly up
to DHA s or and does not that skimming
increase the cost billing made by the
hospital or provider
to the federal government through the
state
I
to the federal government
so the base the cost basis goes up which
means they get more money
which means
everybody else has to pay more I'm
trying to figure that one out if you can
if that's a whole food I'll answer your
first question the same way for both
questions Department of Health and Human
Services can better explain to you
um
how the Medicaid enhancement tax revenue
is matched federally and how it is spent
via disproportionate share
um
disproportionate share payments so we're
basically collecting the Medicaid
enhancement tax and essentially turning
it over in whole to DHHS in order for
them to spend
um through the dish program
thank you
representative almie
thank you I believe that most most of
the disproportionate share goes to the
County nursing homes
doesn't it so disproportionate share is
um going to go to
um
it's going to go to the hospitals that
pay the Met
we're going to talk about the nursing
facility quality assessment right that's
separate yeah yeah this one is is our
own hospitals correct so the hospitals
that pay into met will be the ones that
will receive the disproportionate share
payments they do not necessarily receive
the same amount in Dish as they paid in
met
that changed a number of years ago so
they received based on the formula in
statute a portion of the Met
based on the calculation and statute but
it is not and no longer a one for one
met to Dish calculation
follow-up thank you and that is required
by the FED correct because
on we set up this scheme 20 something
years ago on I think it was Meryl wasn't
it or
and on it was essentially to get free
money out of the feds to use as we as we
wished and we were using it in the
hospital systems but
we were just getting it getting their
share from them and giving it back to
them in the same day
and we weren't supposed to talk about
on that I was I was part of the group
that had to create this contract with
hospitals which took a lot of doing
um
but I think we haven't changed it much
since that time have we correct I the
the majority of the changes were made
starting in the 2014 time frame
um and so we've been operating under the
settlement agreement with the hospitals
and the statutory construction since
that time but my main question was on
how different has the non-binding
estimate been from the final from the
final over the years they're usually
very accurate
um because of the the delay essentially
between the end of the hospitals
um fiscal year and the Met taxable
period that it applies to hospitals
generally know the amount of method
that's going to be due so their
page 44 we just again show a historical
trend of met you can see it's you know
increasing pretty consistently year over
year you'll see that dip in fiscal year
21. that's an impact of covid and the
fact that a lot of elective procedures
non-emergency hospitalizations
Etc did not occur during that time so
that decreased the the base for the Met
um but you can see it you know continued
as I've already kind of mentioned dra's
role in the administration of met so
they file the non-binding estimate with
us on January 15th we notify HHS of that
amount then the returns and the payments
are received on the by the 15th of April
and we deposit that money into the
uncompensated care and Medicaid fund
that's established under RSA 167 colon
64. and the commissioner of HHS is
responsible for expending those funds we
have the authority to audit and collect
any outstanding met Revenue so we have
the audit and a collection ability and
on slide 46 this is the nursing facility
quality assessment it operates very
similarly to the Met it's just a tax on
net patient revenues of nursing
facilities five and a half percent tax
the assessments paid by the nursing
facility as well as facilities licensed
as a specialty hospital and certified to
receive federal reimbursement as a
nursing facility
this rather than the Met having a
year-long taxable period the assessment
period for nfqa is split into quarters
and so each facility files are returned
by the 10th of the month following the
expiration of the quarter and they pay
and file their return at the same time
on slide 47 you can see again the
10-year trend
with respect to the nursing facility
and on slide 48 again our role in in the
administration of nfqa again we return
the money we deposit the money directly
into the nursing facility trust fund and
the commissioner of HHS is the one
all right moving on to I'm sorry we have
a question representative almond yes the
chart for on page 47 only goes only goes
through
um 2020.
and it was going up at that point but
we've got severe stabbing shortages now
so
that's a good point we we'll get you
we'll get you an updated chart
um I'm not sure if it wasn't updated or
if
the labels are incorrect
um I would note though if you look at
the amounts here we're fluctuating
between
37.3 million and 40.6 so it looks like a
lot of fluctuation but the scale I think
is kind of what's causing that but we'll
we'll make sure that we get you an
foreign
so the next text item is utility
property tax upt
rs83-ft this text represents point zero
one percent of the 2.9 billion that's
administered by the dra the tax rate is
uh 6.60 cents per one thousand dollars
of value of utility property and the
taxes on the value of the UT property
and so that's determined by the dra on
December 1st uh of the each of each year
so this tax is paid on so on or before
May 1st each year the company Michelle
file the form detailing the company's
actual Financial operating performance
since April 1 of the prior year and then
the final payment is due on or before
January 15th and this as with other
taxes the estimates are required
and sorry I'm going to interject for
just one second one thing I want to just
point about upt is it is a property tax
so you will see the reference to April
1st so we are looking for the value of
the property as of April 1st it's a
point in time that's different than the
other taxes that we've talked about
where we're talking about a taxable
period we're talking about the activity
of a business over 12 months
so just noting property taxes tend to
look at just a singular point in time so
that's why you'll see the reference to
April 1st we're looking for the value as
of April 1st
representative ulery
thank you for my question Mr King
um looking at your chart it looks like a
Sawtooth pattern is beginning to develop
and
it looks like it starts right about the
time we changed uh the assessment Pro
representative of brahmi and this
committee put together a bill to change
the assessment of utilities properties
uh
at about the time this pattern starts to
develop
the first question is is this a Sawtooth
pattern going to continue up and down
across the the Baseline of the plan of
40.
um in your estimate
guesstimate I guess right I'm sorry
that's the first question go ahead all
right from from our understanding of
this sort of pattern is because of uh
credits that's being available for the
uh for the utility property companies
when they have credits on account so
they won't be paying that much in terms
of uh the taxes because they're using
update credit so therefore in the Years
where they have credits that the revenue
will be down and then the next year and
make the estimate payments that that
Revenue would go up so that's the the uh
the indicate indication of that that's
the sign of that saw tooth yeah
thank you and oh one follow-up follow-up
um the effect of this Taxation and just
for the record and for several members
who know the effect of this taxation on
the consumer rate because the consumers
are the ones that ultimately are paying
this
is what we have that information are you
in coordination with the puc on that
because all the utilities I believe are
regulated there's no
except for
in-house private utility companies
I'm not correct
we don't have specific information about
how much the utility property tax versus
a local property tax versus other taxes
that the entity or the utilities might
pay directly impact
um the consumer rates you're correct
that they do it's an expense of the
business and so to the extent that
they're regulated it would be passed on
to the consumer but we don't have a
breakdown for what upt like I said
versus the local property tax Etc would
have
okay
moving on to the next text type is
railroad tags uh page 51 uh as Lindsay
mentioned for the other for upt railroad
tax is also a property type tax
um and it's taxed on every railroad
Railway Express and every policy being
all Dining Car Company
and the tax is on the market value of
the properties fall through and full and
True Value as of April one and there you
see again the the reference to April one
um
so the railroad property applies to both
railroad companies and private rail cars
operated for profits on on any Railroad
in New Hampshire so it's only on the
rails that is in New Hampshire and not
and went for oh no before it May 1st of
each year the company shall file a form
detailing the company's actual Financial
operating performance and uh so similar
to the upt as well you follow financial
performance and then pay the taxes after
that so payment is due within 30 days
from the date of notice of value of tax
bill
yes representative Ames thank you
um
this question relates back to the
utility property tax as well and it's uh
in both cases Ray wrote on utilities
dras I understand it determines the
value of the property
and um
so I my question is over time how is
that value
changed in terms of increased value or
is it stayed flat you're getting a 6.60
rate on the value so one would it sounds
like the value has stayed flat I don't
know why it would
um is there litigation
that's all related to uh on on your
determination of value brought by the
utilities
sure so yes the dra determines the value
of the properties for both the utility
property tax and the railroad tax
the property taxpayers have the ability
to appeal that value and some do each
year and that process goes through a
hearing uh well first there's potential
negotiation for settlement than if the
department and the taxpayer cannot reach
an agreement then that would go to
hearing at the dra and then could go on
to the board of tax and land appeals
Superior Court and supreme court if
necessary we haven't had any appeals go
um the
the value that we set for the property
is is four in the case of the utility
property tax for RSA 83f but a number of
municipalities use that same value for
the local property value within their
municipality but not all some also value
the property themselves through a
private independent assessor so it
depends on the municipality whether they
use r value or whether they determine
their own local value if they determine
their own local value then there could
be litigation associated with that but
that would be outside of the work that
we do
representative ulrey
half a million dollars for what
for operating a tourist attraction
um
it's on the books and we administer it
okay on page 52.
the more property taxes so this is the
Statewide education property tax
the taxes assessed and collected by the
municipalities to be retained for use by
their local school district the taxes
assessed to everyone owning real
property in the state except those that
pay the utility property tax or the
railroad tax
and the department sets the the rate at
a level sufficient to generate revenue
of 363 million dollars I would note that
that amount was reduced to 263 million
for fiscal year 23 there was a one-year
100 million dollar reduction the
legislature decided to use surplus funds
to essentially bridge that Gap and the
rate is set to the nearest half cent
necessary to generate the revenue
required
property taxes are based on local
assessed valuations and they're
administered and collected by the
individual cities and towns
most property taxes are collected based
on the market value of the property at
its highest and best use and there are
various exemptions credits and deferrals
including elderly and blind exemptions
veterans tax credit
solar and wood Heating and Energy System
representative Olney thank you I just
like your opinion
um there's a a lawsuit
against the Statewide property tax
at this point and the last time that
there was one on
the legislature at least thought that it
was tied to the county tax and the
Cooperative School District tax on
um they're all structured to be
evaluated across
across multiple locally assist
valuations
uh
do you
see any possibility that from that
lawsuit that it
I am not aware of any reason why it
would affect the County taxes so when we
set tax rates at dra to your point we're
looking at the total assessed value of
the municipality and then we're looking
at the amount that needs to be raised
for swept we're looking at the amount
that needs to be raised for the county
we're looking at the amount that needs
to be raised for the municipality and
the local school district and we're
using that value to determine all of
those
but it's just a essentially a simple
math exercise where we look at how much
running needs to be raised for the
county and we divide it by the total
taxable property total assessed value
and that's how we figure out the rate so
they are when you look at your tax bill
you know if you're if the tax rate in
your town is 26 dollars per thousand
that's going to be the total of all the
rates but they're essentially calculated
individually
I believe that that well I know that
that first lawsuit was based on the fact
that the state had totally forgotten
about its constitutional uh obligation
to oversee the assessments every five
years
so we do monitor the assessments we
ensure that they are that every
municipality does a full reevaluation
every five years some municipalities to
decide to do it more frequently we
monitor to make sure that they are done
at least every five years and then we
monitor compliance to make sure that
those revaluations and reassessments are
done
um
in
in an acceptable way to the standards
that have provide that have been adopted
under law
so we didn't forget
anymore
representative Ames
well just to clarify and I know that you
know this because you're actively
involved in this litigation indirectly
by providing affidavits and such
the issue now in swept is unique to
swept
because the issue is whether
what is called excess swept Revenue
can stay in the back within the town
that has collected that excess above
adequacy above the cost of adequacy
that's that's the issue that's being
hotly litigated as we speak halfway
through the briefing process and in mid
bar early March I think a briefing will
be over and it'll be in the hands of the
judge so it's an important issue and uh
is this I'm saying this just because
this is an opportunity to report back on
an issue that also relates to one of my
bills yes correct all right on to the
excavation tab okay
slides 54 and 55 are the excavation tax
and the timber tax also known as Sticks
and Stones
these are taxes that are assessed by and
paid to the local assessing officials so
these this is Municipal Revenue but the
dra is tasked with assisting the
municipalities with administering these
taxes I won't go into detail about them
the rates are included here just know
that we help the municipalities ensure
that the proper amount of tax is is
collected and paid to the local
municipalities
foreign
so the next slide slide 55 this is the
timing of the Dre revenues and just note
that this data is based on the average
of fiscal year 22 20 to 22 of from the
Das Revenue Focus data
um so this will be a very helpful Tool
uh table uh when you're trying to
consider okay when is the um when are
the times of the year that you'll see
the majority of the income coming in and
just using the business the first table
there on the left as an example you'll
see that the majority the higher the
higher months where the incomes are
coming in are in September December and
then in March and April and then in June
and those are the years of when the
estimates uh to be paid
um and then in March and April that's
also the the time of the months where
the Partnerships returns are due as well
as the corporate returns that you
um and then you'll see moving on to MNR
uh usually it's kind it's more of a flat
kind of a expectation in terms of when
revenues are coming in except for in
August and September
and those are the higher months probably
when those the times when activities for
m r are higher for the for the state
and tobacco similarly there's also a
flat
um
expectation for revenues on on a monthly
basis
um because the tobacco tax is collected
on a monthly basis and similar with an
MNR as well it's all collected on a
monthly basis
and then for IND you'll also see the
similar uh
peaks in September uh in the the months
of where the estimates are coming in uh
September and then December and then in
January
uh and then in April
as well as for red similarly it's all
it's more driven by activity
and you'll see that the activities for
red transactions likely um because it's
on a uh the month after so it's uh
activities in July but then collected in
August and then activities in August
and
all right and and then the the section
be below that is just a quarterly
breakdown uh which is easier to follow
in terms of when you want to see each uh
the the money is coming in for each
quarter and then the sections under that
is on the bi-annual
I would just notify Ken before your
question
um
this is important when you're or we're
working with you on doing Revenue
estimates because we are going to
estimate fiscal year 23 first to come up
with a base and then we're going to
estimate growth rates for 24 and 25.
we're going to use when we do this we're
going to use data through January so
just over half of the year
I would point out IND in particular when
you look at the data for the first half
of the year of IND you've received just
under 30 of the total revenue for the
year you still have almost 70 percent of
the revenue still to come in
so this can be helpful when we're
talking about Revenue estimating looking
at the amount of Revenue we've seen year
to date if we were to see something
extreme with IND I would caution and
tell you well we haven't seen most of
the revenue yet most of that revenue is
still to come so this is really just to
inform you about how we're going to
estimate fiscal 23.
thank you uh representative Schamberg
thank you Mr chairman uh just a question
on the business percentage of money in
the quarterly the tobacco percentage of
money and the rent percentage of money
is there any particular reason why those
come out to 101 versus the others that
rounding
rounding you're pretty quick with your
math what's that that was quick math yes
it was just checking all right thank you
sorry I'm not sure that that on this
year is going to be any less atypical so
no but you bring up you bring up a good
point especially for business taxes
where during covid there were some
extended due dates that caused at the
federal level that caused us to receive
money
um a little bit out of whack and that
would be included in that fiscal 20 to
22 so we should probably look at a
longer time frame
and the next slide slide 56 uh the
resources for where we uh compiled the
data to provide to
to prepare this presentation
um the annual report essentially is a
very good Tool uh we we published the
annual report annually it's available on
yes
right it's available on our website uh
for download
um and it has a lot of data in terms of
History especially especially if any of
the members here would want to know more
about the history of each tax type it is
there on in the annual report
um and then the transparency page are
documents that's available on our
website on the top right hand corner
there's a transparency link and you
click on that you have it bring you to
the pie chart in terms of the the total
uh the breakdown of all the revenue
types that's administered and then
further down that's you can drill down
further uh into the uh different text
types and the data that's available
there
and then we also use data from the daily
revenue updates tax expenditure report
is the I'm assuming the annual report
um
we can get either is it historical we
goes back certain number of years okay
great
yeah
any questions so okay representative
if we want to be added to the
distribution list we should let you know
I hope you're sending it to all of us
thank you
representative Ames now you're going to
get it through yeah uh the reference to
the tax expenditure report reminds me of
the legislative committee to review his
tax expenditures I don't remember the
exact name but as tax expenditures in it
which I think is a continuing committee
and uh
um we needed to get it going again I
think that's just an opportunity to flag
this that uh that need to be
appointments made to that committee it's
a
you know it changes every two years
because legislators change but um I was
on it last year and so were several
people others from this committee who
makes who makes the appointments uh the
governor uh no no uh probably the
speaker and the Senate President
representative almond uh I'm calling
representative Ami yeah and I
about a month ago sent an email to uh oh
what's her name in the speaker's office
um
and I said I wanted to be on the
dedicated fund committee again and I
explained to her who had been on the
dedicated fund committee and on
she took that and ran with it so it
needs some initiative From Below because
they have all of these committees they
have to appoint people to so if we want
something in in my case we just needed
people to be in place by June
uh
but
but that's the same for yours because
yeah I wrote both of them
so I think that would be a good one for
a chair or moisture to uh
push forward it's important review
process sort of ensures we're looking at
what we call tax expenditures which are
credits that uh that are a way of
what moving money or keeping money in a
place where
policy says it will do good we want to
make sure that that's happening that way
okay thank you excuse me Brett was that
Jennifer Maybe
no okay
all right
um
okay we can continue
okay so slide 57 we're going to give you
a little preview about what we're gonna
do when we're back here on Thursday so
hopefully the goal is you have at least
a very high level understanding of the
various tax types so that we can help
you start the revenue estimating process
as I mentioned a couple times we start
with trying to estimate where fiscal
year 23 is going to end up and we do
that by running a few very few scenarios
first we say what if Revenue was just
equal to plan
then we say what if we took actual
Revenue through January and that we were
equal to plan for the rest of the year
third scenario what if we took actual
Revenue through January and revenue for
the remaining months of the year equaled
prior year
then the last two scenarios we run
we say what if Revenue through January
and then our percent difference from
plan year to date remained for the rest
of the year so we're five percent above
plan year to date let's assume we remain
five percent above plan for the rest of
the year and then that same percentage
change versus prior year so if we are 10
ahead of Prior year year to date let's
assume we stay 10 ahead of Prior year
for the rest of the year so we're going
to run these five scenarios and we're
going to look at them based on the
knowledge that we have and kind of say
yeah you know what we've been 20 ahead
of plan all year there's no way that
revenue is actually going to be equal to
plan we'll throw that one out so we'll
come back to you with what we think are
the two most likely scenarios of what
we're going to see
in fiscal 23
then we're going to give you a range of
growth rates for 24 and 25 so you're
going to take fiscal 23 revenue and then
you're going to grow it for 24 and
you're going to grow it again for 25.
it may be negative growth depending on
the tax type we're talking about but
I'll use the term growth
when we are doing the scenarios for
fiscal 23 and then the growth rates for
24 and 25 will also work with you to
keep to take into account
changes to existing tax law so for
instance the I and D phase out we have
estimates of what that Revenue impact
will be and we'll work those into the
revenue estimates so let's say we're
going to grow we'll use an extreme
example let's say we're going to grow I
and D by 50 but we know that the impact
of the rate reduction as IND starts to
phase out is 20 million we'll grow it by
50 and then we'll take the 20 million
out
what we won't worry about and this is
Chris in the lba's job where we're not
going to worry about is any changes to
legislation that this committee or any
other committees or the Senate is
currently considering those changes will
happen in the Surplus statement and the
LBA will put that together so we don't
need to worry about any of the bills
you've heard so far all of that will
happen in the Surplus statement we'll
just worry about current law as it
exists today
representative plett has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
the question
um
do you rank order
which will present in terms of least
Revenue impact or most Revenue impact
uh tax by tax
we tend to just give you the what we
feel is the most reasonable range
I understand that but having done that
one tax is going to prove three million
one's going to produce 30 million one's
going to approach 50 million and so on
can rank order them you want us to do
them
highest I'm sorry I'm not understanding
the question
I um I'm asking again to this for the
least tax impact of volume for one tax
to bigger bigger bigger or the other way
around right so so we we could perhaps
take the bottom layer of revenues and
just accept and then go dig into I see
what you're saying
sure so
um what we'll do when we come in on
Thursday is we'll kind of present all of
the revenues to you so that you can
understand what we're talking about and
then with Chris you'll end the chair and
vice chair I think you'll work on
determining what revenues you want to
tackle first and to your point there may
be some that you know the revenue
estimate right away so you can just get
those out of the way and then save the
more difficult work for later so I think
there's flexibility in the order in
which you take the taxes
yes that's correct we can take them up
in whatever order we want and typically
we will start with the ones that aren't
varying too much and um and make those
those estimates and um and then and then
go to the more difficult ones as we get
more information
representative ulery
thank you Mr chair
um Tennessee recently went through an
IND reduction that I think that's the
most recent state
can we get something from them to show
what happened there
so we have
just a general idea I think their IND
was a a lot bigger hit than ours will be
and I'm just trying to to
balance yeah we can we can look and see
if there's anything that we can glean
from that to your point their their IND
it was a larger tax base much larger
revenue and when um when we're looking
at the fiscal impact of the IND repeal
it's pretty formulaic just in terms of
it was taxed at five percent we know
what the base is
um and then we kind of just recalculate
for each of the various rates but we'll
look and see if there's anything that we
can kind of gleam from what happened in
Tennessee follow up yes um yeah well
there's two things one you said you know
what the tax base is except it's changed
because of uh a couple of factors which
we've already discussed but that's we
need to hear that uh we're not on topic
exactly uh in talking with some uh
representatives from Tennessee they were
hesitant
very concerned about going forward with
their ID and then pleasantly surprised
uh could you talk to your Cal our
colleagues and determine why they were
pleasantly surprised sure
uh we'll see what we can find out yeah I
would just be kind of interesting so it
gives us a place to start uh somebody
else has gone through this already and
let the volunteers figure it out sure
any other questions Revenue kind of
estimating process and we'll be here
along with Chris uh throughout all of it
with you so
okay
slide 58 I just wanted to take a couple
of minutes
um to I guess both update and inform the
committee I know there are some
Representatives who've been on the
committee for a while but I know a
number of you are new so I just wanted
to kind of get everybody up to speed on
what the dra refers to as our Revenue
information management system or rims
so the dra received a 30 million one
hundred and sixty thousand dollar
Capital appropriation to replace our
aging tax information system known as
Tims
we do taxes we're not the most creative
people so cut us a break on the the
naming we replaced Tims with rims
Tim's was implemented in 1990 it was
obsolete it was very limited in its
functionality it was a cobalt-based
system so black background you know
Green flashing cursor no ability to use
a mouse everything was function keys
um and what's wrong with that
it's it's
tried and true technology but
things have come a long way in the past
uh 30 years punch machines
so rims is used internally at dra and is
also used by taxpayers and practitioners
we implemented it in conjunction with
doit and again it's a complete overall
of our back end technology system and it
really Consolidated many disparate
systems into one
fast Enterprises was selected through an
RFP process to provide their commercial
off-the-shelf or cots software known as
gentax fast and gen tax operate in many
many many states this is what they do
they do Tax Administration and they do
it well so we feel lucky to have
partnered with them the implementation
of rims was consisted of three phases
each took about a year and the contract
also includes support and maintenance
the total cost for that contract was 29
million five hundred and fifty thousand
dollars
on slide 59 you can see the various
rollouts we had three roll outs as I
mentioned we started with the meals and
rentals tax Medicaid enhancement tax and
nfqa we moved into our larger tax types
of business taxes interests and
dividends and communication Services tax
and then in the third and final rollout
we implemented tobacco ret upt Etc
I will note all of these rollouts were
on time and on budget you will see they
go right through the covid-19 pandemic
we pivoted at the time we worked from
home we did everything that was
necessary and we remained on time in our
budget so I'm very proud of that work
our employees and our vendor worked very
hard and it really propelled the dra
forward
we we have a question from
um
for the operation of this I was as you
know part of this entire thing yeah
um at least on the edge yeah the
on the web yeah there you go I saw you
spot uh the question I'm asking is and
we asked this one back in 2017-2018.
this was intended to make dra more
efficient it was intended to reduce some
of the Manpower because you would
replace that with machine power
it was also uh intended to be more
consumer friendly
uh I take from this presentation and
from your general attitude regarding
this and the degree of the material we
found some of those goals have been met
have they been met was I I'm trying to
justify the expenditure of the 30
million dollars to people that perhaps
don't necessarily want the government to
spend money on government
sure
so I would say an overwhelming yes to to
all of your questions rims
um delivered what we thought it could
and should deliver
in terms of efficiency we are able to
process all of our returns deal with all
taxpayer interactions requests for
refunds Etc and in very timely manner we
did not see significant delays in the
work that we produce as a result of the
hiring shortages that all businesses and
government has felt over the past few
years we have been operating at about 15
percent vacancy rate for close to a year
and a half two years now and everything
is still happening on time so people
should not be experiencing any delays as
a result of the Staffing shortage and
that is due to the fact that rims is
more efficient
we have a we've been able to
reallocate resources to work that used
to have long backlogs because rims is
more efficient so
um you know for instance you know
processing a maintenance request from a
taxpayer we had to process returns into
the system that was the first priority
and then we could work on maintenance
for the taxpayer now the returns get
processed so much easier through the
system that employees that used to do
that can now work on taxpayer
maintenance so we have seen kind of all
of those benefits that we hope to see
in internally at dra in terms of for the
taxpayers and practitioners on slide 60
this is just an example
um it's a copy of the front page of
granite tax connect so Granite tax
connect is our online web portal so it
allows taxpayers and practitioners to
access their account to see the payment
that you made that the check was
actually cashed to look at your current
account status none of that
functionality existed before rims if you
had a question about your account you
would call into our call center and they
would answer your question in a very
polite and timely way but you couldn't
do it at 12 o'clock at night you'd have
to wait for our business hours you
couldn't do it on the weekend Etc so
this is a picture of GTC
I will call out for you a few things
that even without a granite tax connect
account you can apply for a meals and
rentals tax license you can make a
payment we will take your money you can
request a payment plan you can upload a
Power of Attorney form if you have a new
power of attorney you can send that to
us right through GTC without having to
create an account so these are just a
few things that you can do like I said
even without utilizing a full GTC
account
um another benefit if you are a taxpayer
and you're using GTC and you're stuck
you're trying to file a return let's say
and you're stuck you can't figure out
you know what button you're supposed to
hit next or what information goes where
if you call into our call center you can
provide them with a session ID number
that shows on your screen and they can
watch what you're doing so they can
provide you real-time assistance so you
don't have to worry about spinning your
wheels and not being able to effectuate
what you need to in the system
um our call center is wonderful
um we have five people dedicated
full-time to our call center additional
employees fill in as needed there's a
survey at the end of the call if
anyone's ever called in you get a survey
you can rate US from one to five on our
professionalism and one to five on our
knowledge we routinely receive very high
marks you also have the ability to leave
a message and that's kind of my favorite
part I get a summary of all the messages
at the end of each week and people
routinely praise us for just answering
the phone
um apparently that's a novel idea these
days but just how helpful our employees
are and a lot of that is because of rims
and the ability for both taxpayers
practitioners and the dra to be seeing
the same data at the same time
there's one last piece of the rims
benefit that I
um I think you also might be interested
in which is on Slide 61.
so part of the reason or part of the way
that the legislature funded rims was the
30 million one hundred and sixty
thousand dollar appropriation
but the interest the principle and
interest on those bonds six million is
paid for by the general fund but the
remaining 24 million one hundred and
sixty thousand dollars of principle and
interest is actually funded by Revenue
uplift that's resulted from the system
so we anticipated that there would be a
benefit to the system
um and so we have
um under statute are required to
transfer money into a dedicated fund to
pay the principal and interest and we're
going to do that until the fund reaches
40 million dollars which is what we
anticipate the total principal and
interest to be on that 24 million one
hundred and sixty thousand dollars and
on slide 62 you can see what we've done
with that to date so we're going to
transfer 40 million dollars in total but
we cannot transfer more than four
um so in fiscal 2020 that was the first
year that rims was operational we did
not transfer any money the system was
just up and running we hadn't received
any additional uplift in fiscal year 22
we Tran or 21 excuse me we transferred
2.2 million dollars and then in fiscal
22 we transferred the four the full four
million dollars
you will see in the chart at the bottom
the total revenue uplift we realized in
fiscal 22 was actually 5.3 million but
we were capped at that four million
dollar amount so that's why it was only
4 million and not the 5.3
we've done this
um we've achieved this Revenue uplift in
a couple of a couple of ways one is
um the system allows us to automatically
send a reminder to pay letter
so before rims we would issue a tax
notice
and we would not contact you again until
you didn't pay that notice and you ended
up in collections
now after 30 days we send you a nice
note that just reminds you that we had
sent you
a bill and that you need to pay it and
so just that reminder has generated
a good portion of this amount
we also now have more efficient use of
data that we receive from the federal
government in order to ensure compliance
with with New Hampshire laws so we can
look at Federal data we can see that a
business may have a filing obligation we
can see that they have not met their
filing obligation in New Hampshire and
we can proactively reach out to that
business so better use of federal tax
I have a question then we'll go to
others
um
I believe I have a login to this system
and I and I I guess my question is if
you have multiple and can you have
multiple entities on the same login you
can so if you were an uh restaurant for
instance you could have your meals and
rentals tax license and also your
business tax license would show under
the same login if you operate multiple
businesses you can have multiple
businesses show under your login if you
are a tax preparer you can
um
log into your account and so long as
your clients have granted you access you
can see the various accounts of your
different clients and what you can do
under those accounts might differ for
each client right I might say sure
representative you can look at my
account but I don't want you filing
anything on my behalf
Keane may say you can file all my
returns for me
um so taxpayers can set those individual
parameters
for their their practitioners okay great
thank you we'll start on this side of
the room this time represent ours
thank you Mr chair thanks for uh that
report it's very interesting that you're
able to do that through to covid having
worked with the Department of Defense in
London Scotland and here in a couple of
agencies auditing and com uh as a
program manager
it's impressive that you did it on time
on budget I hope you got an award you're
you and your team thank you thank you
yes representative Bolton
regarding the um the needs to go from
Cobalt which is not supported to at
least a platform that is supported now
is it being maintained off-site or is it
is do it maintaining it so
that's a great question so it's um
I guess a little bit of a hybrid so the
the actual physical Hardware is located
here in New Hampshire at Hazen drive and
the maintenance of the system is done in
conjunction with dra employees doit
employees and we do still have vendor
employees on site so at the height of
implementation we were probably at 30 to
35 vendor employees and we're down to
about eight to ten I anticipate and
we're asking for in our operating budget
to maintain a level of the vendor
employees for a couple more years as we
make sure that we can continue to
maintain this system because it is such
a big change going from the Cobalt
system to this more modern system pull
up
follow-up follow-up
um so regarding
um the maintenance that do it on Hayes
and drive
um they have normal business hours and
you want us to support outside of
business hours correct so we have an
agreement with the vendor for um 24 7
monitoring so we do have the ability to
make sure that the system is up and
running at all times so they have remote
monitoring for the times that we're not
okay representative Almy
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question commissioner stepp I
think yes you are to be commended for
this uh implementation I was here and uh
year when we looked at that 30 million
and said let's go so it's and your
report out today was uh really nice to
hear all that I have a question about
that 29 million uh
consult a fee uh maybe it was it was
buried in all those numbers that you put
through there but uh that 29 million is
coming from where how does that factor
into the uh sir where does that come
from sure so the 29 million 550 000 is
from the 30 million one hundred and
sixty thousand dollar Capital
appropriation
um and that was funding for the
three-year implementation of rims
um Basic Hardware and software
maintenance for seven years and some
additional post implementation support
we will be requesting in our operating
budget to kind of maintain that
additional post implementation support
the difference between the 29 550 and
the 3160 is we had
um a vendor Barry done perform
Independent Health assessments of the
project as we went through it so they
would come in a couple times a year they
would look at documentation about the
the status of the project they would
interview
doit staff dra staff and vendor staff to
make sure that the project was healthy I
felt nervous about being in charge of 30
million dollars
um for one project and wanted to make
sure that the project was moving along
smoothly because on any given day the
project manager of the vendor could have
been like yeah yeah everything's fine
and I worried we would get to the end of
the project and we would be missing
things or things wouldn't be the way
that they should be so we we contracted
with Barry Dunn to do these periodic
Health assessments I can provide anyone
that would like a copy of them they were
all glowing and they reassured us that
we were on the right track in terms of
making sure that this project was going
foreign
does that same vendor provide security
or is there another vendor that provides
security for the system
so security is provided through fast
Enterprises however we have contracted
recently with new Harbor through Dubai T
to do a security assessment and to do
penetration testing and we will keep up
those assessments with the assistance of
vendors and doit going forward so we
make sure that the system is functional
but also secure thank you
money is
increases in males and Romans interest
in dividends probably some of the others
as well
on does it get
removed from the amount that shows up at
some point on each year
good question so the amounts are
transferred once the fiscal year has
closed and would be accounted for in the
ACT first so if you're looking at Cash
basis numbers which is what we typically
look at the cash basis numbers will
include this four million dollars
they're essentially removed in the
accounting adjustments that happen
between the close of the year and the
act for so they show up in the kafir
correct
thank you Mr chairman a great overview
of the
process I noticed on a page 40 an
example you listed factors influence and
revenue you did that on a bunch of the
pages
the dra uses historical Trends and does
static analysis
do you see
any probability of the dra using an
organization to do future probability
analysis to help you
maybe see what a trend is going to be in
the future
I think that's a a great question
um
as you mentioned we have typically in
the past done a static analysis so we
have looked at you know if this change
were to have happened last year how
would last year's revenues be impacted
by that change
we have not when we do that sort of
analysis we don't take into account
um
would that change influence behavior and
therefore then cause revenues of maybe
another tax type to increase or decrease
or revenues within that tax type to
increase or decrease
um
I think the the hardest thing about
doing a more Dynamic analysis is one
Manpower
um we are a small agency and a small
group that does this work
um so certainly with additional Staffing
that's
um something that we might be able to
consider or with additional funding we
could contract out to a consultant or a
third party that does that sort of work
the other thing that I would know is
that typically that sort of work
um a more Dynamic analysis is usually
fairly time consuming and we're
operating under pretty
um strict time constraints within a
legislative session this is no fault of
Chris's but when the LBA sends us a
fiscal note to complete they asked for
it back within five days because they're
trying to get it on the bill and get the
bill published so you all can have that
information
five days is probably not enough time
for us to do a more sophisticated
Dynamic analysis that being said though
there may be opportunities where a tax
policy choice or tax policy
consideration or option that could be
evaluated over a longer period of time
and not the five-day turnaround for a
fiscal note could benefit from that sort
of analysis something that comes to mind
is you know the school funding
commission that operated a few years ago
that commission had an appropriation to
spend money on a consultant to have
those resources to provide that
so long story short it's a resource
whether it's people money or time
constraint
representative Ellery
two things to know keep the first one to
um
this issue and the second one deals with
how could you find out how much Watson
costs per hour just let us know
I mean I can put a line in my operating
budget for Watson a crystal ball a magic
eight ball I look for crystal balls
there's a damned expensive okay
um and then just for the committee sure
um
I think uh representative Murray wanted
to tell us all about uh put your
so um the the news is that uh
uh Gary Hopper uh honorable Gary foper
has has died
I'm sorry to hear that
representative Almy
thank you I had one small question and a
something else about the dynamic
analysis options on a small question is
are people who file by paper
still allowed to do it they are still
allowed to do it we
do not have a Prohibition against paper
filing some states do we are not one of
those
we have as part of the front end of our
rims system we have two high-speed
scanners that process those paper
returns so if you fill out a return
online
um and print it and mail it to us
there's a 2d barcode that's generated as
part of that return and our scanners
pick up the information that you entered
through that 2D barcode if you hand
write your return many people do our
scanners are able to read handwriting
um and they will well they will attempt
to read handwriting I will say and for
anything that this scanner has trouble
reading it will prompt a human our data
entry folks will be prompted to review
what the return says and enter the
amounts we will or we did receive some
arpa funds to upgrade our scanner
because one of our scanners is at the
end of life so we will be disposing of
that scanner we will be purchasing a
brand new scanner and we will be
rehabbing our existing scanner so that
we can still have two running at the
same time my biggest fear is that our
scanners go down on April 16th so we
always want to make sure that we have 2
two of them going at any time
we also obviously receive electronic
returns so similar to you filing your
federal tax return via the irs's
modified e-file program you would file
your return essentially goes to the IRS
the IRS carves off the New Hampshire
piece and sends it to us so we also
receive many returns electronically but
we're always happy to have paper as well
thank you and could I follow up meant
this is not a follow-up this is okay
about the dynamic analysis I was going
to put in a bill
this year and I had a health emergency
and I had prepared it two months ahead
of time and I've forgot about it
during that brief window we had on which
looks at something like but I think that
the only place that does it is Remy
on Remy
on
original
[Music]
macro no Regional economic macro macro
economic uh and I never can remember
what the I stands for but they have been
uh
working for 40 years now the gentleman
that started it
built an original model to look at at on
trying to predict the future for things
like this on and they work only and
there there are I think 28 of them in
total on in the countries they are based
in DC but they have an office in Amherst
Massachusetts
and they work with States and
municipalities only and counties they
will not work with non-governmental
institutions
and we actually a couple of us uh
representative Schamberg and I and Jerry
Stringham we'd hope to have back in the
committee uh he's in finance
on
talked with them this Summer and we
wanted as a next step to be bringing in
on
representative abrami to this
conversation that didn't work out either
uh
but uh it when we talked to them we
discovered that we already have a Remy
group in New Hampshire it consists of
gotlop Ryan gottlow
and he went to
um
the on security
employment security group because they
would let him do this
it's been
working in multivariate analysis all of
his life and this is kind of the gold
star of it as far as I've been able to
determine but um
I went in skeptical I don't know I did
too representative almond do you have a
question first it's not really a
question is just information as this is
an alternative that uh we could put
somewhere and you were talking about
things that
we can't re it can't be contracted out
it has to be something with one person
somewhere in the institution and the
bill I put in was to try to to set up a
commission to decide where and how and
if of course
but
okay thank you
um any questions on the presentation as
a whole any of the taxes that um
okay seeing none thank you very much a
great presentation very informative
thank you we'll see you on Thursday
all right so
tomorrow we have
so
um I guess going back to a
representative plett's suggestion of
you know hitting these in order of um
size I mean we don't necessarily do that
correct it's more like we start with the
ones that are more predictable
and um so if you can correct I think it
takes sweat for example it's a 363
million dollar
uh Revenue stream
set by Statute you're going to get that
same amount so this committee can easily
make a decision that they want to stick
with that number unless you're going to
introduce something new related to that
um I think what you've seen this
committee do is tackle what we would
consider those easier Revenue sources
such as a lot of what the agencies that
have already come into you so maybe
Insurance
um maybe the securities
you know um maybe the HHS amounts so you
might look at some of these and say okay
as a group we don't feel we can have
anything to add or change to those
Revenue estimates that they provided so
we can feel comfortable with those
numbers the ones that you tend to
um focus on and spend a little bit more
time with would be the things like your
business taxes your ret your IND
um your meals and rooms those seem to be
the taxes where there's a little bit
more flexibility a little bit more
thought put into because there's a lot
more influencing how those taxes come in
um what our our job is or my job is is
to provide you with a worksheet and help
guide you through the process but you
direct that process overall so you
decide when when you're ready to say
this is the tax we want to work on today
so on as a segue
um Thursday you're going to be meeting
you're going to start with dra so the
commissioner and her team will come back
and they'll give you some of their
estimates related to the revenue streams
that you need to do projections for
they'll take as much time on Thursday as
they need to with you and when they're
done I'll come up to the table and say
okay here's these other Revenue taxes
excuse me these other revenues that if
you're comfortable you can start making
some decisions but if you're not and you
think you need an agency to come back
let me know so that I can get them
scheduled to come back for you
so that will be the second part of
Thursday again I don't know how long all
this will take and it's you need to be
comfortable with the information you
you're getting
um yep between now and Thursday if
people have questions please shoot them
my way you know the email call me
particularly if it's related to the dra
stuff so that I can let the commissioner
know so they can come prepared to
respond to that
um
also you've got scheduled dates in
February February 27th and 28th and
March 1st to come back and finalize I
think your estimates right now you have
the governor's budget director coming in
on the 27th he was originally scheduled
to come in on the 26th
22nd but that date has been canceled due
to potential session day so he'll be
available to answer any questions you
might have as it relates to the
governor's Revenue estimates on that
Tuesday February 28th you have
um Employment Security coming back with
an update the committee had requested
last week if you could have that if we
could have them come back to provide
some information to you as in terms of
Workforce issues they might be seeing in
terms of good or bad Trends so that's
going to be their focus but they also
understand there may be other employment
related questions that may come to them
so that's who I have for you in the next
two weeks
excellent uh we have some questions
thank you
um when can you tell me what the
governor's estimates are going to look
like is it going to be a spreadsheet or
and do we get it before
his director comes and speaks to us so
we can look at it and think about
questions
so tomorrow when the governor comes and
presents to the legislature you'll have
a an executive summary that will be
presented so it'll be a printed document
in there would be the revenues and they
would be listed similar to you see the
unrestricted revenues listed now so
you'd see his projections for 23 24 and
25.
so it wouldn't be in a spreadsheet per
se it'll be in a table format but but
Chris you'll end up putting them into a
spreadsheet for us yes so the worksheet
that we keep talking about that many of
you probably haven't seen
um will have the governor's information
included on that so it should be a
One-Stop shop for you so you'd have a
document in front of you that you'll be
able to see
um 22's planned revenues what the ACT
first 22 revenues were 23 plan then the
governor's estimates agency estimates
um
and then your estimates and that would
be the same for 24 and 25. follow up and
so when when we get it in that format
the one that you've put together we'll
have more back history a couple more
columns going back so we can look at
pre-covered
not necessarily no it just shows you 22
23 24 25. I
the the back history would be in some of
the information you've been Gathering to
this point the act for has the 10-year
plan or excuse me the 10-year showing of
revenues so you can get a sense of how
but if there's something specific I
think last uh last week you had asked
about the tobacco settlement money and
there was a request to have a 10-year
look at that and I've sent something out
to the committee related to that to
basically show the projections that were
made by the doj and then where the
representative ulery
thank you just just so the committee is
clear we're not looking at the budget
we're only looking at the governor's
estimates and our estimates the budget
itself will be up at the top of the hall
and finance and they get what 1200 Pages
or so uh
stuff
there's another word for that but
okay
representative almi
thank you uh
two things we we used to get uh much
more information from insurance about
the context of their numbers
and then we've gotten this time
they would talk to us about hard markets
and soft markets and on the property and
Casualty versus the the on health and
Etc on and I didn't see any of that in
what we got I just saw some numbers
uh that's I think I think you're
absolutely correct
um if the committee would like them to
come back and go deeper into their how
they get to their revenue estimates that
would be an agency we could ask to come
back on the 27th or 28th whether the
market is hard or soft in various
categories does change what their
numbers are I think the commissioner
touched upon that briefly during the
presentation but it wasn't written in
the in the presentation
but again I I take direction from the
committee if the committee's decision is
to have them come back then I I will do
that so I would defer to the the chair
and vice chair to let me know who they
need to have come back do we do you
remember how much variability we
typically see
um not from what they plan to what you
actually collect well from year to year
I would say no I mean I think compared
to what they present to you and what
they actually collect are fairly similar
numbers there may be some slight
adjustments up
um and I think you're seeing that right
now
I sent out to the committee at a revised
estimate for 23 for insurance it also
had Lottery commissions information on
it I sent that out on Friday
um so you'll see that they bump their
number up from 135 million 423 up to 139
million but it didn't have any impact on
the 24-25 estimates again it's partly
because of the way they collect that
Revenue stream
right thank you
um representative roachford yes thank
you um so we've heard a lot of taxes and
one of the taxes that I've seen just in
passing and uh and we haven't expanded
on it because maybe it's dedicated as
the beer tax
foreign
that was in with Liquor's presentation
it was one line
no that that's fine because it doesn't
really get talked about it's about 13.1
to 2 million a year
um it doesn't change really there's not
much fluctuation to that what the Liquor
Commission has testified to in the past
is that the
um
what you've seen is a
shifting towards some of the more
microbrew type beers and away from that
you are more traditional beers but the
overall Revenue has not changed as it
relates to that and that revenue is
based on the gallons sold there's a 30
Cent tax
yep
yep they all need to be distributed
through Central points within New
Hampshire there's certain Distributors
that manage that and collect that tax
for the The Liquor Commission
all right any uh representative Almy
thank you my other
request was that we get
the 10-year
on
compendion of taxes uh that's in kafir
with the ETF and the GF combined so that
we can
that it kind I I can put that together
for the committee if it's something that
I've spent a lot of time over the years
all right anything else
thank you Chris
you're welcome
so
that pretty much concludes uh our
activities today
um so let's see going forward tomorrow
you all know we have a house session
Wednesday we'll be back here
uh 10 o'clock we'll be uh in exec
session
first on HB 288 297 and 569.
and then
from 10 30 roughly from 10 30 on we'll
be uh we'll have I didn't write those
down we have public hearings on
Wednesday is the exact session
at the beginning Then followed by
public hearings
okay
no 569 is an exec yeah
yeah
and then of course Thursday then we'll
be back here on Thursday
the 16th 10 o'clock for Revenue
estimates we'll start that process
well yeah you we
in general we shouldn't have four four
days up here is that's
uh yes
so our Wednesday we're meeting at 10 A.M
Wednesday yes 10 a.m okay and is there a
caucus before the session on Tuesday
um yes nine okay thank you
breakfast across the street
oh before the session tomorrow you're
I figured it would end around 12. 12
o'clock
did a good job
[Music]
I will process
Ary